we should have some kind of minimum
Level Health Care system for everybody
and it would it would actually be
cheaper than what we have what we have
includes people that go to the emergency
room as primary care which is insanely
expensive sometimes they don't pay their
bills and that leads to everybody who
does have health insurance is just
absorbing that cost it would just be
cheaper if we provided everybody some
basic level of care there are states
that have done it I think that's just a
basic thing
um and secondly I would like to
socialize some aspect of paid
um uh family leave
parental and and maternal not hugely
expensive it's economically at least
stimulative in the sense that when other
countries have done it they find that
productivity ends up being higher when
parents return to work and you know it's
been widely studied